Good morning Hank, it's Monday, January 3rd,
2011. Happy four year Youtube-versary! I dressed
up cause, you know, it's our special day.
So Hank, in today's video I though I would
answer some of Google's auto-correct's common
questions beginning with 'is b.' Okay, let's
start from the bottom "is Bearshare safe?"
No, but neither are ice pick lobotomies, which
we don't use anymore either. "Is Bob Harper
gay?" By the way, Bob Harper is a guy on The
Biggest Loser.
Let me answer your question with question,
Google. If we spend as much time thinking
about quantum physics as we do thinking about
whether celebrities are gay, do you think
we'd have a unified theory yet? I do!
"Is Bam Margera still married?" Yes, technically
although he and his wife live in different
cities. "Is Beyonce pregnant 2010?" No. "Is
Brett Favre married?" Yes. "Is Beezid a scam?"
No, it's just a rip-off. "Is Beyonce pregnant?"
Still no. "Is Bronchitis contagious?" Yes.
"Is bleach over?" No and lastly "is black
a color?"
Finally an interesting question! The answer
is yes and no. Functionally, it's a color.
If we mix all the primary colors together
we get something that very much resembles
black. But on the other hand, technically,
blackness is the absence of light, which is
a chromatic.
Then, Hank, I kept typing 'is b' until eventually
I typed 'is benj' and after the question of
whether Natalie Portman's fiance is Jewish
you come to "is Benjamin Button real?"
Hold on Hank, I have to make a quick journey
over to my desk. Ah headdesk!
Then we have "is Benjamin Franklin a president?"
A question with its present tense and indefinite
article implies either that we have more than
one president of the United States or that
Benjamin Franklin may be a member of the Presidents
of the United States of America. Sadly, neither
is the case. Benjamin Franklin was never the
president of the United States and he certainly
isn't now. In fact, it is my sad duty to inform
the googlers of the world that Benjamin Franklin,
American hero, patriot, non-president, has
died. Yes, Hank, the good always leave us
too soon. And Benjamin Franklin was a mere
84 years old when he died 221 years ago.
So anyway, Hank, I kept playing around and
then eventually I googled 'is bieb?' "Is Bieber
gay, german for basketball, in jail, bi, a
girl, really 51, dead, or going to North Korea?"
Also, "is bieberfever.com free?" Hank, you'll
be surprised to learn that the answer to all
these questions is either no or ahhhh.
So Hank, welcome to 2011, a year when Google
believed we wanted to know whether a popstar
was a deceased, imprisoned, fifty-one-year-old,
gay, bisexual, female, german basketball on
its way to North Korea. Hank, I think it's
safe to say that we did not imagine that world
on January 1st, 2007.
Nerdfighters, thanks for sticking with us
all this time we're gonna continue Monday-Wednesday-Friday
videos in 2011 but we have heard you that
you want more question videos, more Thoughts
from Places, and more info-tational videos.
And we are here to grant your wishes as long
as your wishes aren't weird.
To that end, I will be doing a question Tuesday
video this Friday so please leave questions
in the comments. I will answer as many of
them as I can in four minutes. Hank, DFTBA,
I will see you on Friday. Wednesday, right.
What you think my mental calendar suddenly's
going to improve after four years?
Oh, and by the way still nothing.